it's a very common misconception that
the main religious texts of christianity
islam and judaism are full of stories
involving angels and demons there are
some that are indeed named and mentioned
however there are even fewer ever
elaborated upon
most of what we know comes from
religious scholars and historians who
wrote accompanying texts to essentially
fill in the gaps which means there are
varying accounts and several
disagreements
samael is an angel who is portrayed in
several different ways and will be the
topic of today's discussion as we
attempt to unravel some of the mysteries
behind what many refer to as the angel
of death
some may remember in the video
discussing lilith we did mention samael
in regards to the fall of adam and eve
these writings predominantly come from
what is known as the second temple
period which lasted from 516 bc to
around 70 a.d
the talmud and its surrounding text
place samael as a member of the heavenly
host which essentially means the army of
angels at god's disposal
it's common here for him to be referred
to as the head of satans gustav davidson
and his work surrounding angels call
samael the chief of satans now satan
here is not referring to satan himself
the devil or lucifer it's using satan in
terms of the title which many believe to
mean a range of things from accuser to
enemy or adversary it's fair to assume
here the title is referring to man's
gracious adversary which is sin
after all samael is the chief angel of
sin
many texts take this and compare samael
to azazel and lucifer however in these
particular examples he may not be an
angel you wish to encounter but he very
much remains a servant of god
in the teachings of rabbi eliezer and
several others it is samael rather than
lucifer who is the one charged for
taking the form of a serpent and
seducing eve in the garden of eden they
even go as far to say that eve was
seduced by samael and from this cain was
born samael being the father the story
differs in regards to the serpent some
believe samael transformed into a
serpent and others merely that he was
able to use the serpent to do his
bidding there are even some wilder
variations where samael rode a giant
serpent like a camel
in barrack 3 or the greek apocalypse of
barrack after praying for answers an
angel is sent from god to escort barrack
through the heavens and give him the
answers he seeks
in the third heaven he asked the angel
to show him the tree which led adam
astray
and the angel said to me it is the vine
which the angel samuel planted where at
the lord god was angry and he cursed him
and his plant again we see the notion
that the tree and fruits were not placed
in the garden by god instead it was
samael and given god's reaction it was
clearly not done at his request
thus the fall of man can be blamed in
part on samael
many of the texts samayal appears in are
either hebrew scripture or midrash
however the greek apocalypse of barak is
a book many believe was taken out of the
bible
in rome however samael was seen as a
guardian angel and a positive protective
figure
in the stories that pair lilith and
samael together we see him turn his back
on god and so we also begin to see the
idea that samael was linked to demons
just as much as he is to angels
when lilith rebelled against god he
feared together with samael they would
flood the earth with demons and so
samael was castrated but not before he
was able to sire an army of demonic
offspring
in heaven samael is described as
stirring up jealousy and creating
hostility amongst the holy delegation
samael spreading the doubt of god's
teachings extends outside of heaven
in the binding of isaac when god tells
abraham that he must sacrifice his son
isaac abraham as one would expect
questions this decision
there to sow the seeds of doubt and
convince abraham to disobey god is
samael
when abraham rejected samael's offer
despite abraham he went straight to his
wife sarah and told her that her son
isaac had been sacrificed the news
killed her immediately
there is a story from a spanish cabalist
that claims he was able to bind the
samael he summoned samael in the name of
god and bound him by placing a crown on
his head that said thy master's name is
upon thee
samael however was able to trick the
kabbalist and free himself
in these kabbalistic teachings exists
the clepote which are also known as the
tree of death the opposite to the holy
sephiroth or the tree of life they
represent the ten divine attributes
whereas the clepote represent evil and
impurity samael is described as the
chief of the ten evil demons that oppose
the tree of life
if we go back to the work of gustav
davidson he breaks down the name into
two parts sam meaning poison and l
meaning angel which is why one of the
many titles given to samael is the
poison of god samael is the angel
responsible for bringing the poison of
death into the world now this could also
be referring to his role as the angel of
death or perhaps even his union with
lilith the spread of this demonic
offspring could be seen as the poison
when we discuss the book of enoch the
leader of the watchers was the angel
samyaza given the similarity in name
many believe samyaza and samael refer to
the same entity gustav davidson's
description is as follows
in the secrets of enoch he is the prince
of demons and a magician
samael has been regarded as both evil
and good
as one of the greatest and as one of the
fouler spirits operating in heaven on
earth and in hell
on one hand he is said to be the ruler
of the fifth heaven on the other hand he
is the great serpent with twelve wings
that draws after him in his fall the
solar system much how lucifer is
depicted as a great dragon samael was a
twelve-winged entity of sorts whether it
was a dragon serpent or something else
is never really elaborated upon
there are some passages that discuss the
position of samael before his betrayal
before his defeat in this war samael
held a place higher than the holy
heavenly creatures and the seraphim
which indicates a high level of
importance and trust by god
again we can see that samael is a figure
that confuses most scholars not only
because of how closely linked he is to
lucifer but whether he should be placed
in heaven or hell whether he is a
servant or an adversary of god
in the book of barrack for the role he
played in the fall of adam and eve he is
cursed to become satan
samael also makes an appearance in the
testament of moses here moses recalls
seeing two angels each of which were
five thousand parsangs tall a passang is
the modern day equivalent to about three
miles
gazing upon these giants made moses feel
uneasy but the angel metatron appeared
to embrace him as a favorite of god he
ensured moses there was nothing to fear
moses then came across another angel it
would have taken 500 years to cover a
distance equal to it and from the crown
of his head to the soles of his feet he
was studded with glaring eyes
when moses asked who this was metatron
replied
this is samayal who takes the soul away
from man
in gnostic belief samael is referred to
as the first sinner whose name means
blind god which also applies to his
followers a direct comparison to the
christian devil here he appears as a
lion-faced serpent
in the quran he is compared to a figure
known as samiri who is also an accuser
and deceiver
before looking into samael in detail i
knew that he was a polarizing and
confusing figure the angel who serves
god in a thankless task against the sin
of man or the rebel who became a demon
prince and was feared by humanity
i was hoping by the end of this to have
a more definitive answer as to who
samael was however as we've seen today
that is not the case most of the written
accounts vary or contradict themselves
to the point where it's safe to assume
no one really knows who samuel was or
what purpose he served to fulfill
so to summarize today's findings after
looking into samael i can confirm he is
indeed a polarizing and confusing figure
but hopefully you've enjoyed this one
anyway
as always
i've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
you